they're three conclusively proven
benefits from cannabis ok treatment of
chronic pain treatment of chemotherapy
induced nausea again this is some of the
medical community services are
concretely it works he called nicotine
the most reliable cognitive enhancer
that we currently have question of the
day before we get into this uh do you
produce smoke cigars at all how many you
got there uh partake in the wacky
tabacky there you go the marijuana so
this is I wanted to talk I really I
wonder if your opinions have changed in
this I wanted to talk there isn't really
a whole lot of balanced or I guess it
tees were nuanced discussion of
marijuana out there for that matter
tobacco you get people who are radical
on either side matter of fact I think
the super pro marijuana lobby now they
have a lot of good arguments but they're
sort of near the anti tobacco lobby
where they've really overshot their
target so this is a quick segment to
hopefully you present a balanced view of
the benefits and they are real for both
and drawbacks and of both marijuana and
tobacco and really more so kind of their
their active chemicals first thing I
want to say is they're very important in
a similar uh they're very similar sorry
an important way rather in that most of
the research related to both marijuana
or cannabis I know people like don't do
marijuana was a DEA term in Canada and
tobacco man most of the research is not
its preclinical at best and that's
because we haven't been able to study
either of them very well so with
marijuana that's because it's a Schedule
one drug which I absolutely am against I
think most people who even think that
marijuana is bad for you of course
should still we still should be allowed
to have some kind of medical research
and then nicotine hasn't been studied a
whole lot because it's been the face of
one of the greatest public health
scourge is and subsequent Crusades the
last century really so you don't have a
ton of it so I want to make sure that
I'm very clear the research there is
scarce thought let's go to the benefits
a little limited let's go to the
benefits of marijuana first there are
some scientifically proven uses for
marijuana okay I want to be really good
there was a 2017 meta-analysis of over
ten thousand studies I think oh and they
essentially find that there's three
conclusively proven benefits from
cannabis ok treatment of chronic pain in
adults and I want to be really clear
this is chronic neuropathic pain for
people like I didn't choose for move
then I decided to smoke a joint instead
of take the pic that doesn't work at all
okay the kind of lights going to be in a
lot of pain and paranoid about the
dentist's tools you forget it's the
sciatic nerve pain I have something
that's like myalgia treatment of
chemotherapy induced nausea again this
is some of the medical community
services are concretely it works and
then treating symptoms of multiple
sclerosis yeah
then there are some maybe other
therapeutic effects like improving sleep
you can look up all of these studies on
unpublish I think it's important to be
honest about the benefits yeah as well
as the drawbacks because some people
tell you that it cures everything
something else that's really important
for people to not look use and why are
you putting glaucoma on there here's the
thing you can have marijuana help with
the condition right but it may not be
super effective and it's significantly
less effective with more side effects
and other drugs available yes you do
like glaucoma they have better drugs
that last longer and are more effective
and so at that point say okay just like
anything else just like other conditions
we have a more effective drug for that
but it doesn't help no and it may be one
of the most effective drugs currently
available for neuropathic for chronic
neuropathic pain and those conditions
that we talked about so something else a
lot of people may be surprised when I
say benefits of tobacco or its active
constituent here in nicotine
controversial I know
nicotine when separated by the way from
the dangerous habit of cigarettes
specifically inhaled to back not the
boogeyman it's made out to be I know
you're gonna say well just try to
justify this habit alright an order of
safety it goes it goes cigarettes and
then like cigarette and then probably
chew yeah and snuff what is it the
Swedes snus in the nose snooze I don't
know and then it goes down the nose and
it goes probably cigars and pipes
because right and then it would go to
like vaporized [ __ ] to pure nicotine or
nicotine gum nicotine by itself actually
eliminated from tobacco when they did
studies and was almost impossible for
them to get the mice addicted to
nicotine by itself really without the
other actually these are my studies so
that I'm getting off on the field
owl stoned so a recent evidence but it
probably better than Fievel goes west
that's equal really sucked and
coast/west all right he was pissed off a
recent FDA study found that smokers of
one to two cigars per day the increased
risk of cancer is statistically nearly
insignificant and in 1900 on its good no
increase mortality rate just want to be
clear about that there are some cities
where pipe smokers live longer so bill
did I know you're smaller Asian and you
smoke a pipes you're gonna live till a
hundred and five yeah by the way there
are a lot of neuro protective elements
to nicotine that have been proven
studies have shown that it's actually
inversely correlated with
neurodegenerative conditions like
Parkinson's disease yeah okay they're
even sitting nicotine right now is an
adjunct therapy and this is this is
pretty controversial it's not a secret
by the way to anyone who's used it
nicotine of course helps with visual
attention working memory even
prospective memory which means
prospective memory as opposed to working
memory means kind of the ability to sort
of make plans then remember them and
follow-through
does not help you just need a good
sativa for what for what there was one
there ain't no draft no more see what
you're saying here about the nicotine
again to be clear you're not saying
cigarettes correct
no of cigarettes in 2018 oh my god
second though because of San Francisco
banning all the vapes and so people now
are just gonna be smoking cigarettes
more but as a matter it is such a so
well-known noted psychology has actually
been cited quite a bit I want to make
sure I have her name right here Jennifer
rusted roosted I don't know she's from
the University of Sussex in Britain she
called nicotine the most reliable
cognitive enhancer that we currently
have oh wow that's a doctor not myself
there you go there's an appeal to
authority fallacy because I like my
cigars HIPAA notification Bell join
Michael but let us credit.com that smoke
limit you have not already it's able to
continue you with this show on you right
and of course subscribe a 19-0 reading
let's go to the draw back so that
everyone now in the comment section say
both draw back and this should be
something like you want someone like me
on your side okay do you want people
like the people in this room normal
first row pot heads do not necessarily
partake saying okay maybe there's
something
here we want to see some more research I
certainly don't want people going to
jail for non-violent drug-related crimes
let's get to some of the drawbacks with
with cannabis couldn't people get mad
that even say marijuana and one is
pretty undeniable okay marijuana is
harmful to the developing brain meaning
it has permanent deficits people who use
it before the age of 25
same reason you can't rent a car without
paying a fee until you're tight by the
other year is more controversial these
the two proven clinically proven
drawbacks of cannabis there seems to be
pretty solid consensus among scientists
and psychologists that meant that
marijuana exacerbates psychiatric
conditions right the very least can act
as a trigger to those who are already
predisposed to them yes hey want to be
clear drawbacks tobacco
similarly smoking tobacco products by
the way can cause cancer obviously again
this is mainly in relation to cigarettes
also when inhaled cigarettes clearly
extremely addictive again though the
rats couldn't get addicted to nicotine
by itself and I say this is all new
partakes and all of us here either
occasionally smoke cigars or pipes it's
cuz you fortunately smoke em every day
and if I if you know if I don't feel
like it I don't feel like it yeah
exactly I've never once been like I'm
making for us well and everybody just
they they kind of conflate nicotine with
cigarettes every time they hear nicotine
they think cigarettes and I think all
the additives and all the bad stuff that
is in cigarettes it is obvious from
improving and that's why it's hard to
study right exactly the other part of
that is I know what people are gonna say
because whenever you want to get into
the science of this folks are gonna go
but so what you're saying is that cigars
are not dangerous they have no increased
risk well there's a difference between a
certain small degree of risk which is
certainly there is more risk of getting
cancer from tobacco products if you're
using them than if you're not
cheeseburgers exactly yeah but there's a
big difference between cigarettes and my
car yes but here's the category think
about this the the positive effects the
relaxing effects reduce stress that you
can have from smoke a cigar or not not a
ton of cigars but a little bit right
that's how I suspect with pipe smoker
and that was a meta-analysis and even
then when they isolated it for the
cancer I don't think we had these
overlays I think what the pipe smokers I
said it was like an increase of two to
four percent chance of like esophageal
cancer less of an increased chance from
non-coffee drinkers to coffee drinkers
and they attribute that to actually
drinking hot beverages this isn't a
lotta people don't know
yerba mate a is like a popular drink now
yeah
they found very high in antioxidants but
those people would have all kinds of
esophageal and mouth cancer and the
reason why I thought they drink it
boiling hot out of a gourd often with a
metal straw well it's like sitting on a
putting your mouth out on a sundial
[Laughter]
itself is what's on screwing up all the
cells in there I mean not again that
there isn't some perhaps increased risk
with certain types of we're not saying
you can't eat soup yes yes it should be
lukewarm little bit that's all sour
anytime a delicious egg drop wondering
and I want to be cook at the pro anti
debacle Lobby they've gone way over
London so wrap just like kind of the pro
popular we're talking about so far over
the line that they now even try to
downplay safer alternatives like vaping
we don't have that problem in Europe
they recognize vaping isolated nicotine
as far safer than smoking cigarettes but
in San Francisco you can't even have
Nick juices shipped or jewel products
shipped to your house but from what I
understand they still sell cigarettes in
the Bay Area yeah so what do you think
is going to happen like oh gosh I really
I can't use what I use to quit
cigarettes yeah exactly with all the
problems that San Francisco has them I'm
surprised they're focusing on this one
if you could just get people not to
defecate in the street and live yeah
right intense around every single corner
that would be a good idea by the way
that also brings us to some of the big
money shadow figures a lot of people
don't know this the the pro marijuana
lobby they have a lot of big billionaire
backers too people say oh you're paid by
big pharma world George Soros is a
fronted a lot of organizations that push
the cannabis and something else that
push the cannabis that sounds like
something crazy you a lot of loners to
look into the relationships between big
marijuana in Canada because they all
have to kind of go through Canada right
now since it's gotten the green light
from you know from from the government
they're big corporations I don't know if
it's endeavor around house or bush
they're now looking in cannabis into
cannabis drinks when people say oh big
pharma but you're paid by big pharma if
you have any opinion other than cannabis
works for everything well what about the
big corporations who are who are selling
your marijuana now this legal you hate
big corporations as a general rule but
all of a sudden they toss a little bit
of THC isolate into your soda they're
inherently altruistic and there's a
gigantic corporations betting huge on
this right now so this is not like a
small mom-and-pop
feel the growing pot yes and that is
going to be something very interesting
because just like a with alcohol with
marijuana the the bulk of purchases come
from people who chronically consume it
doesn't end well people who occasionally
consume so if they're making these
marijuana infused you know like
beverages things like that that are
going to be released in Canada and of
course places states where it's legal
well do they have to create a drink to
sell to the people who already partake
in marijuana regularly in which case it
has to be a much higher dosage you want
to reach new users they want to create a
new market share which of course tobacco
companies were vilified for doing in
which case so they would have to sell a
product that really doesn't cater to
their base so it'll be interesting to
see how this shakes out and I want to
know everyone else out there thinks as
your mind change at all on on medical
marijuana recreational marijuana and
what's your opinion who do you think who
do you think is more powerful the
tobacco lobby we've been told of the
book or the Anto - anti tobacco lobby
hey if you like this video subscribe or
hit the notification bell I think you
see some videos playing in boxes up
above but you may or may not know we've
been demonetized on YouTube so you can
actually support this channel by joining
mug Club lot of credit com / mug club
you get this wonderful handouts mug
along with hours of content every week
the full daily show that you don't get
here on YouTube also if you want to see
this with the hemp if you want to see
nip Mac can be on YouTube you got to
join mug club nips for bug Club